direction blois à présent où le projet
d'un quatrième pont sur la loire était
dévoilé aujourd'hui la passerelle qui
empruntera dès 2024 les piles de
l'ancien barrage sera réservée aux
piétons cyclistes et cavaliers
investissement total 12 millions d'euros
découverte avec sébastien branger dans
quelques années cette passerelle
enjambera la loire un ouvrage d'art de
380 mètres conçue pour les piétons les
cyclistes voire même pour les chevaux
c'est quand même 380 mètres de long je
sais pas c'est pas une promenade très
très simple si on veut la faire à toute
vitesse mais voudra il faut prendre le
temps du temps le temps d'être en balcon
sur le fleuve dans des lieux dans les
séquences pour ces cultive un peu
différente
une fois avec les oiseaux sur l'île et
les sternes une fois dans une alcôve une
autre fois en balcon sur le fleuve une
réalisation estimée à 12 millions
d'euros financés par la région l'état le
département et agglopolys serrar osé est
exceptionnel mais c'est à la hauteur de
l'enjeu
on est quand même sur un fleuve d'une
beauté exceptionnelle
on est sur le dernier fleuve sauvage
d'europe 1 comme on dit communément mais
il ya eu un développement touristique
très important il ya une population qui
demande des loisirs de pleine nature de
plus en plus fort et bien cette
passerelle ça va être ce trait d'union
le site choisi n'est pas anodin il
s'agit de celui de l'ancien barrage du
lac de loire construit dans les années
70 et détruit en partie il y à une
quinzaine d'années ce sont sur ces piles
de béton que reposeront les piliers de
la future passerelle on avait souhaité
garder ses piles en se disant qu'un jour
ou l'autre il y aura peut-être un projet
qui pourrait les réutiliser c'était
aussi assez a trop fuyant pour la nature
d'enlever des blocs de béton assez
important ils ont été conservés et
finalement on a bien fait dé conserver
puisqu'on va devoir se poser dessus et
venir faire cette passerelle sans avoir
à amener de béton quasiment pas c'est
plutôt une bonne chose sur le plan
écologique
enfin le viaduc des noëls à proximité de
la rd 951 devrait être prolongée pour
enjamber la route
les travaux devraient débuter dès 2023
et se terminer en 2024